[Aplausos]
la atención volvió a estallar alrededor
de la mezquita de alcasa entre la
policía israelí y los manifestantes
palestinos luego de que la corte suprema
de israel retrasará la polémica decisión
sobre si los palestinos del barrio se
quejará pueden ser desalojados por la
fuerza para dar paso a los asentamientos
israelíes más los judíos no han cambiado
de opinión tienen la misma estrategia
quieren desalojar a los palestinos
buscan la manera de desalojar a los
palestinos la forma que tenían a su
disposición fue bloqueada
ahora buscan una forma diferente el
primer ministro israelí benyamín
netanyahu prometió restaurar el orden en
jerusalén este pero las imágenes de la
brutalidad de las fuerzas del orden
israelíes han suscitado críticas en todo
el mundo en jordania uno de los seis
países árabes que mantienen relaciones
diplomáticas con la nación hebrea se
llevaron a cabo protestas frente a la
embajada de israel
israel no respetan en sus acuerdos
internacionales con los árabes ni sus
compromisos internacionales cada uno
emitió más de 800 resoluciones
internacionales pero israel no cumplió
ni una de ellas
los reclamos en solidaridad con el
pueblo palestino se extendieron también
desde el líbano hasta turquía
mientras los musulmanes no se unan y no
tengan líderes que pongan su corazón en
esto
israel seguirá atacando nosotros estamos
aquí nos solidarizamos con nuestros
hermanos y siempre seguiremos estando a
su lado según la ley hebrea los judíos
que puedan demostrar un título anterior
a la guerra de 1948 que acompañó la
creación del país pueden reclamar sus
propiedades de en jerusalén una norma
que no incluye a los miles de árabes
desplazados y palestinos que perdieron
sus hogares en la ciudad en el mismo
conflicto